what's going on everybody listen there
is a video up on this page right now
about a woman who came to one of my
shows and threw up three times in an
empty margarita glass in the front row
we have it all on camera if you if you
haven't seen it and go down there
it's called his drunk women drunk people
something like that this video must show
you she came back to the show again this
year sat right up front
Oh guys it's drunk woman Redemption it's
so good you have got to check it out but
first before you get to it I got to tell
you about these earbuds wreck on and you
guys know I'm always looking for ones
that fit my ears because I have elven
ears with a weird sized hole rake on
first of all they're the only air buds
that fit my hole because they give you a
lot of different options if it doesn't
fit your hole they give you and smaller
rake on is all about fitting your hole
guys because all of our holes are
different sizes and you know anything
about Ray Con and Ray J they're all
about fit in the hole
you've seen the video here's the thing
guys don't like that when I workout they
don't fall out of my ears the sweat
doesn't get them this is like perfect
and not only that look how cool they
look slick
you wouldn't even know even with my
giant ass elf ears you wouldn't even
know they're in there look at that guys
not only that Snoop wears them I feel
Snoop and I are on the same wavelength a
lot of times I feel like these really
make he and I connect get yourself some
break-ins here's the most important
thing I want to tell you half the price
of the normal the other earbud places
you would go those pricey places we all
need things that I have to price half
the price base is kicking and I want to
read this because I'll never memorize it
and you know why here we go newest model
every day e 25-year buds best ones yet 6
hours of playtime 6 hours nothing 2
hours you get on your pair 6 hours of
playtime seamless bluetooth pairing more
bass in a more compact design that gives
you a nice noise-isolating fit also
comes in different colors not just this
you can get different colors guys whoa
why wouldn't you go and check this out
go to by rate calm calm slash Josh wolf
that's by rate calm calm slash Josh wolf
for fifteen percent off your order
fifty percent off and it's already fifty
percent less than what you're paying now
guys do the math because I don't know
what it is but go to by rate Khan calm
sloshed Josh wolf get 15% off let's go I
hope you enjoy this video later okay so
for those of you don't know so there was
a woman sitting right up front last year
right here with that cup she threw up
three times in the glut
my mother why she didn't throw up like
who's that yeah like you Oh [ __ ]
you're here
[Applause]
wait wait wait let me tell you something
first of all I like the fact that you
ordered the same [ __ ] drink you know
cuz you're no quitter that's all I have
so much respect for Allison I'm not to
tell you why guys let me just get okay
first of all I've told many people about
you
have you seen the video I happen to be
videotaping the night that they have let
me give you a little bit of a rundown
okay all right so I'm not sure if you
even remember when you hear that
meddlesome okay so when you'd be here
hey man how are you in Indians this year
this is your wife unless your husband
all right and so you weren't here last
time yeah and are you here this time to
make sure that no no no no I gotta take
it okay so let me tell you guys about it
so I'm sitting here to [ __ ] bathroom
and and and the imagery writer and so I
am one empty and so we're having a good
time everybody's lab yeah there's a
little bit of low and this is what I
heard from right there by the way you
and I us we were the only people that
knew it was happening in the time you
didn't know either
it was just being you
[Applause]
so here we go I just hear and I look
down she's right here and she's mounted
like this and it and but like a pro real
slowly just reached for the empty
margarita once with not trying to draw
any attention to herself
just slowly run it back your angel
[Laughter]
now let me tell you the couple of things
that I loved about it first of all you
didn't make a big deal out and hey guys
obviously she wanted to stay at the show
right and because you were trying so
hard I was like well I'm not gonna kick
her out she didn't make a mess and
here's the other thing I confidence this
is gonna sound weird but I have
confidence in you for this reason if you
can throw up in your mouth and not how
they did come up it's not your first
rodeo you know what I'm saying so I was
like oh she's no rookie like she knows
what the [ __ ] she's doing I don't want
to get any you know she's a professional
like I don't wanna I don't wanna [ __ ]
that up for everybody and the only
reason she by the way she went on to do
it two more times but every time
didn't bother nobody else notice didn't
bother anybody else it sounds like what
I'm around
she's clearly giving it at all so to
kick around you know to me but then
after the third time she filled up the
cup and I was like well you gotta go you
gotta go now
there's no I'm not gonna get you another
empty cup you know what I mean that's a
little but and here's the other thing
here's why I knew that I didn't have to
worry about you because most most people
if you like right now if you had them if
you think you're gonna puke what would
you do you get the [ __ ] up but you were
just like I'm so happy to see you here
and thank you so much for coming back
and we're at where is the third one
she's working oh that's for me is it
empty margarita
[Laughter]
and I would like to buy that drink
nothing I'd like to buy that in that big
drink I'll buy it put it on your tab she
came home so sorry everybody I asked
these questions for a [ __ ] year when
she came home did you when did you hear
the story she couldn't function yeah
yeah you stayed here that night you went
up there I wish I had known that
[Applause]
while amazing what sign what's your name
Allison to Cindy and gentlemen where
your name's Jeff Ted Jeff house and
Cindy thank you guys so much and thank
you for having four incredibly white
names I appreciate you guys coming thank
you all very much for coming I'm sorry I
had to but you know that doesn't happen
too often and the fact that you're back
and in the front row wind up [ __ ]
wise
[Applause]
go to by rank on com+ Josh wolf for 15%
off your first order that is by race on
comm class Josh wolf 15 but that all get
some
[Music]
you